It's true what Larkin says about
parents, they do mess you up.
They don’t mean to - usually.
But they do.
By the time I'm eight, Dad's mania
and anxiety are kicking in,
and that, mixed with a newfound
fervour for Christianity,
makes things lively.
By age 11, bedtime stories are out
and tales of hell fire are in.
According to Dad,
me and everyone I know
are going to suffer eternal agony
unless we turn to Jesus.
Ah man,
I could save myself...
what about all the people on TV?
All the players on Match of the Day?
Would I have to wait
in the car park after games?
"Mr Cantona...
kicking people is a sin.
Yes, even if they
do support Crystal Palace."
By now Dad is relentless.
And the panic attacks are regular.
Running around the house,
screaming, delirious.
And things deteriorate.
By 12, 13, I'm crying constantly.
Struggling to get out of bed.
And by 14, I'm starving myself.
At 15 I have to have
a year off school
and be treated at a psychiatric ward.
Complex PTSD is a variation
of post-traumatic stress disorder.
We associate that with people
affected by specific incidents.
In war or after an assault
or car crash.
The complex variety refers to those
who endured repeat abuse
usually at the hands of care-givers.
It may have been a religious parent,
a violent parent, one that drank,
sexually abused you,
scapegoated, shamed
or just ignored you.
One common sign of complex PTSD
is an intensely critical inner voice
that just won't get off your back.
You know the one,
that says things like:
"You're useless.
You've achieved nothing."
One negative thought will kick in and
then they'll all come out to play.
"Oh and you look rubbish naked."
"Oh by the way, everybody hates you."
"I can't believe you just stood on
that snail, and you like snails."
Another sign is flashbacks
and these are often more subtle
than specific memories.
The situation you're in now will
remind you, even subconsciously,
of a time that you felt overwhelmed.
For me it's social gatherings.
When I walk into a room I often feel
like I'm about to be humiliated.
So my fight-flight instinct
kicks in hard.
At parties, I'll often go
to the bathroom several times
just to feel calm.
I love bathrooms.
Sitting on the bath
listening to the party downstairs.
[muffled party conversations]
I practice bathroom sound effects too
like the sound a toilet roll makes
when you pull off the last sheet.
After that I'm okay for a bit.
But then someone new
will come up and say:
"Hello, I'm Ted!"
I'll get all adrenalised
and just leave.
There is no danger but the psyche
doesn’t know the difference.
That's complex PTSD in a nutshell.
Sorry Ted.
Other signs are depression,
substance abuse, isolating yourself
and avoiding relationships.
You may have no clue
why you feel any of this.
But there is help.
Self-help books are
a great place to start,
especially if you're nervous
about therapy or talking to a friend.
Therapy's been great too.
Someone to talk to,
help join the dots,
give names to things.
I also try and stay healthy
and clear headed.
Vegan diet, exercise and meditation.
And of course stand-up.
Talk about facing your fear
of humiliation.
I did get to make some peace with my
Dad before he died a few years ago.
A tumour on the brain.
Felt strangely right for a man
so lost in his own mental chaos.
I did love him, he meant well,
he was just negligent and confused
and it caused damage.
It's important to know
where the blame lies.
These feelings aren’t your fault
and it can be helped.
So see it like you see any injury -
listen to it, give it what it needs.
And remember it’s okay to feel bad
but fear, anxiety, anger, depression
ruin all of the good stuff.
All of the fun.
And this
is supposed to be fun.
Thanks for watching.
Don’t forget to subscribe! :)